[Music]
i think the mit museum is a unique place
at least in my experience mit itself of
course is a very special research
institute not like a lot of other
universities and the museum is the only
real institution that mit has to
represent the whole of what it does to
the rest of the world
all museums are
cultural centers we have the culture of
mit
what makes it special what makes it
interesting there are no written records
for most of the things that we have
just the thing itself
so we're part archaeologist part
anthropologist part historian and we
hope to imbue those same qualities in
our visitors every museum of science and
technology in some sense should be a
museum of ideas perhaps what makes this
one special is that many of the ideas we
deal with are ideas in the making ideas
that we're not sure about and some of
the uncertainties some of the challenges
of the research process are also present
here and so they should be
[Music]
the mit museum is
home to an extraordinary set of objects
that define the 19th 20th and 21st
century
doc edgerton's negatives and artifacts
are among the most precious collections
they document a technology high-speed
stroboscopic photography but they also
document the desire to stop time
to see what is unseen
[Music]
the mit museum also has the world's
finest collection of holograms
many of them are on display here in the
museum but much of the collection is
also accessible on our website
[Music]
another collection that we have is
probably the world's best collection of
robotics that were created by
university-based research robots like
cog or kismet the humanoid social robots
very good kismet
there is no other place where you can
see two three dozen objects that tell
the history of artificial intelligence
as well as our collection does
[Music]
the heart nautical collections is a
unique archive of 350 000 items the
interesting thing that is
perhaps unique in all nautical
technology collections
is that we have this amazing amount of
historic data that goes back to the mid
19th century and our collections
continue right up to the present we are
actively collecting technology being
developed today for example the side
scan sonar
systems that we have behind me this is a
type of technology that is equivalent to
the development of the x-ray in medical
imaging this allows us to see details on
the ocean floor that were never before
capable
one of the things that's most vital
about engaging people with interest in
ocean science
is the giant frontier that it represents
i mean we know more about the dark side
of the moon than we know about the ocean
the mit museum is also home to one of
the important architectural study
collections in the country this
documents the first hundred years of
architectural instruction at mit which
was the first academic program in
architecture in the country the recent
exhibition of front and back in our
compton gallery
featured our earliest architectural
drawing attributed to a renaissance
architecture involved sorry perutzi
dating from the 16th century we pulled
it apart looked at all the layers of the
drawing subjected it to scientific
analysis we also took the drawing to
the design labs to 3d model the drawing
to look at
contemporary approaches to
a renaissance drawing in other words we
had really basically no assumptions when
we went into the project
and we came out with a lot more
questions than we started with
but for us that was the process was what
was interesting
soapbox is a new program for adults in
the mit museum the aim is to engage the
wider community a little more closely
in the debate that needs to go on in the
21st century about how we're going to
live and live better with the fruits of
science and technology the issue of
global warming has risen to the top of
the public's agenda
of environmental concerns we've done
everything from biomedical issues
through to uh ways in which new
nanotechnologies new materials will be
changing everyday life after the
speakers have presented the issues for
the evening the audience breaks up into
small discussion groups and brainstorms
what they've heard and it's on the basis
of what the discussion groups come back
with that we organize the rest of the
conversation
so what we're trying to say is here's a
place where you can take part in the
conversations that in the end will help
shape the way we and our children live
in the future
we'd like people to come to think of the
mit museum as an innovative place itself
one of the innovations that we are
leading at the moment is to create a new
cambridge science festival
the idea is to have nine or ten days
each year in the spring
when we open up the entire world of
science and technology in this city
[Music]
what we're planning is a whole series of
events scattered across the community
we're talking about plays science
writing events
exhibits a careers day for young people
and the hope is
that anybody who's awake in cambridge
for that 10 days will realize that the
science festival is on the question is
not so much
when will we build a robot
that is a human being we have this
extraordinary situation where we can
work with colleagues with grad students
and others to try to open up what
they're doing for the wider community
and it's that notion that really is at
the heart of what we're trying to do
with the mit museum as we look forward
that means that we need a lot more space
and it means we also want to expand the
range of what we offer into subject
areas where the museum historically
hasn't done very much we are in the
middle of an exciting renovation of a
ground floor gallery space
that will open up our
collections and our programs and our
exhibitions quite literally to an
outside audience on mass avenue for the
first time we now have ground level
visibility for the museum it's an
important step for us and that space
will allow us to have new exhibitions
and new dedicated public program spaces
which will mean that we can do
things like soapbox much more easily
when uncoiled the dna in one cell of
your body is six feet long science is
something for everyone technology and
science matter that's the most important
message that i hope people leave this
museum with we do see ourselves as
having that kind of inclusivity and that
accessibility agenda an agenda to try to
draw people in to benefit from to enjoy
and if they want to challenge what goes
on in a place like mit
[Music]
you